somebody knows a thing or two about
energy as Texas Senator Ted Cruz Senator
I would imagine instead of doing an
idiotic deal with the Moe's of Iran and
and sucking up to the murdering Thug
dictator in Venezuela Maduro uh and
pegging OPEC only to be rejected again
and again and again to produce more oil
uh I would imagine Texas Oklahoma uh
Alaska would be very open to producing
as much as possible in terms of oil and
West Virginia and Pennsylvania and Ohio
would be open to giving us natural gas
but what do I know I'm just a talk show
host
well Sean you're absolutely right but
but you know as you know the Democrats
are in panic mode that they're in free
fall because they created this crisis
you know I enjoyed watching your video
of Pete bootage talking about wild price
flocculent fluctuations
when Joe Biden became president gasoline
the average price was 2.38 cents a
gallon today it's four dollars and 23
cents a gallon it is nearly doubled in
in 15 months under Joe Biden they've
waged a war on domestic energy
production they canceled the Keystone
Pipeline they shut off leases on federal
lands they shut down Drilling in Anwar
all of that's deliberate it's what Joe
Biden promised he told Democratic
primary voters if you elect me I will
halt Drilling and you know what that's a
promise that he has been working
overtime to keep
and and now the Democrats are in panic
mode because they realize that people
don't like paying four five six you know
in California it's nearly seven dollars
a gallon for gas
and so on inflation the white houses had
five separate lies on inflation their
first lie was it's not happening don't
believe your eyes there is no inflation
their second lie was oh it's transitory
yes it's happening but it's transitory
just for a moment their third lie this
was from Ron Clane is it's a high class
problem it's it's there but it's a high
class problem aren't you lucky to have
inflation their fourth lie was it's
happening it's not transitory it's not
high class but it's a good thing it's a
sign of how great the economy is that
you can't afford to pay for your
groceries or fill your car and then lie
number five that every Biden apparatchik
is repeating is Putin Putin Putin
they've decided politically let's blame
this train wreck of a Biden energy
policy on Vladimir Putin well you know
what the gasoline prices had ridden 48
before Putin invaded Ukraine as the
stickers say on on the gas pumps I did
this Joe Biden did this
you know and what do you make of the
president for example I thought his trip
abroad was a disaster telling our troops
oh you'll get to see it in Ukraine
yourself uh revealing that our troops
America might be training Ukrainian
troops I doubt that's something that
maybe uh we wanted the world to know or
Vladimir Putin to know I would consider
that in the covert operation plausible
deniability category uh then calling for
regime change only to be corrected by
his own staff as they clean up his mask
and then to double down and do it again
after they cleaned up the mess and now
there's no way to clean it up this time
on top of every other gaffe that he
makes your reaction I don't think he's
cognitively up to this job Senator and
it's dangerous look it's it's Gaff after
Gaff after Gaff and the White House team
desperately tries to keep it a gap or is
he is he in a cognitive decline it seems
to me obvious yeah look he's clearly in
major decline I can tell you it's
strange Biden they don't know allow him
to talk to most Republican Senators when
we have lunch together Republican
Senators almost to a person none of us
have spoken to him since he became
president that's weird look Joe Biden
swore me into office 10 years ago we all
know him he served in the senate for
four decades but the White House is
terrified that anyone who interacts with
him realizes he's not up to the task so
they keep him protected they keep him on
talking points they give him a narrow
script and even that he screws up and
you know you've got this war in Ukraine
Joe Biden caused this war in Ukraine how
did he do it when he waived sanctions on
nordstream 2 sanctions that I authored
that I wrote that Donald Trump signed
into law when he waved those sanctions
he let Putin build the natural gas
pipeline to get his gas to Europe which
is why Putin invaded Ukraine the
president of Ukraine told us the reason
Putin invaded Ukraine is because the
nordstream too and I got to say Sean
it's an amazing thing that there is one
Pipeline and one Pipeline on planet
Earth that Joe Biden and his cronies
like and that's Nordstrom too because it
helped Vladimir Putin but if they're
pipelines in Americas that create jobs
here at home they want to shut them all
down can you explain the difference if
you drill for a barrel of oil and one of
the OPEC nations or Venezuela or Iran or
Russia or the United States uh explain
to me what the difference is in terms of
the impact to Mother Earth because I
would argue our guys probably do it
cleaner and better than anybody else but
yet they're okay with importing oil and
begging tyrants for oil yeah but they're
not okay with with drilling our own oil
and using our own resources I can't
explain that one can you you're exactly
right America produces oil and produces
gas cleaner than just about anybody else
on Earth and and what Biden has done is
is hammered U.S production and shifted
production overseas to give you give you
an example of that natural gas
production in the United States and
Texas or in Pennsylvania and Ohio it is
about six times cleaner than production
in Venezuela but Biden wants to put
billions in the pockets of Maduro and
Venezuela of the Ayatollah and Iran of
Putin and Russia and he wants to do it
at the same time that they produce more
oil and gas that pollutes more that
emits more CO2 he's not doing this for
the environment the environment keeps
getting worse because he is reducing
clean U.S production and shifting to
dirty foreign production but the thing
to understand when I talk to leaders in
the energy industry is listen you can't
talk to the Biden Administration with
facts or reason or or substances they
are zealots this is a religious
conviction they want to bankrupt All
American Energy domestic production and
and and you're saying the results of
your gas pump all right Senator Ted Cruz
Texas thank you as always hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else